With these two concepts, states and events in mind,
let's think a little bit about modeling of behavior. Systems that
respond to events are called reactive systems. If you think about it for
a minute that's much different than this other kinds of systems that you would
normally build, in which it's the system in charge of controlling the order in
which things happen. Here is the external world which supplies the stimuli that
are causing things to happen in the system, the system has to react to them.
In general there are a variety of different approaches to modeling behavior.
We're going to go through from the simplest, which is combinatorial systems.
Through sequential systems, to the most complex and
concurrent systems. In combinatorial systems, we're just concerned with states
no events. Sequential systems have states, that is they have memory, but
they're linearly ordered one state after another. And then concurrent systems.
Particularly asynchronous concurrent systems have lots of states and
lots of events and the events are happening at unpredictable moments of time.